you know my parents got divorced I was
14 my mother was very very dominant
domineering personality her complaint
was always that my dad didn't take more
of the lead and that she was resentful
towards him and she definitely did you
know she was even for the rest of her
life I mean she went on to become very
successful in many different ways and
but
[Music]
um saying no like you know my a moment
I'm very proud of like the teenage boy I
was at the time was the day that I
finally had the balls to stand up to her
and tell her no and it was not pretty it
was not pretty at all and uh it was a
series of NOS that end up then having me
like just leave the house uh for good
but it makes me wonder how many how many
young men today because so many are
being raised by single mothers m how
many of them are even saying no to their
mother if it's you know especially if
there somehow she's about to cross a
boundary or it uh it's going to
somehow it goes against his conscience
or whatever the case I mean I I think
that uh I know for myself it was it was
very hard to do because no one likes
to be an to their mother you
know but I wonder I wonder how many
young men today haven't even learned to
say no to their mothers yeah well like
single mother households while their
intention is generally and genuinely
good often they they can't turn boys
into a men they just can't you know
they've tried for decades we've seen
what the results are uh the vast
majority of the incarcerator come from
single mother households runaway teens
single mother households teenage
pregnancy single mother households
teenage pregnancy genes like you know
you keep going right down the list and
and the results aren't good I think if
you compare the data to to single father
households which is I mean it's a much
different smaller subset there's fewer
uh children that are raised by their
fathers whether their wi or you know
whatever it happens to be but um I think
single mother households generally
speaking are regarded by those that
understand what they're about are
essentially beta factories uh they turn
boys into to Beta males they turn boys
into these agreeable plated softer
mushier version of masculine men that
preceded them and that's just a function
of the nurture right so I think one of
the things that boys if they're watching
this that are younger or men that might
you know perhaps uh not have good access
to their uh Sons and Daughters you know
should contemplate is good a good access
to strong virtuous men that are good at
good at being men and are good men is is
only going to be a positive service you
know for children but women don't get it
they don't understand that you know they
think that because a child comes out of
their body that they own the rights to
it and that's one of the problems in in
family court today is you see a lot of
women still fighting for custody and
courts still give the vast majority of
custody orders you know to mothers um
but they but they don't do it for the
right reasons like these women are
generally doing it because there's
Financial incentives for uh child
support when they're the primary
caregiver they get a lot more money if
they have the kids 80% of the time
versus 5050 you know it's just the way
that it works and it's not just money to
cover the costs of being a parent and
you know putting clothes on the kids
back and taking them the
extracurriculars it's it's considerably
more than what's required to cover those
basic costs uh they also have the power
to make unilateral decisions without the
father's consent in many places in the
world um you know if they want to if
they meet Bill the guy from the uh
accounting department at the company
that they work at where they're the
receptionist they want to get married
and move state or there's a job
relocation if she's a primary caregiver
and has custody often she can do it
without the father's consent she can
just take the kid and leave she wants to
hyphenate the kid's last name or perform
a medical procedure the father may not
necessarily agree with that's fine you
know so I think you know the whole
notion that women are uh raising most
children today I think the number is
something like 43% of kids in North
America are being raised in a single
parent household they don't say single
mom because that's disparaging but
they'll say single parent household but
we all know the vast majority of kids
today are being raised by their mothers
and again you know women are great at
lots of things like nurturing softness
loving you know stuff like that like
they're more agreeable on a balance of
probabilities and what men are but they
don't turn boys into men like I said
earlier they turn boys into these uh
essentially pathetic beta meals they
what they generally do to sort of like
clarify that a little bit further is
they turn their sons into the men that
they want essentially to be within a
long-term basis right so it's why you
see a lot of these boys that are just
basically Mama's Boys Like You Hear
women today oh I'm tired of dealing with
these M's boys they still live at home
or you know the mom does a laundry and
cooks for them and they expect that sort
of thing you know for from me um I think
that a lot of these guys you know these
women turn into men that they think uh
boys should become
agreeable which is hilarious because we
also know in another breath that women
aren't that attracted to men that are
agreeable and plated and say yes to
everything they want to be with a giant
they want to be with a leader they want
to you know be with a guy that can make
it rain that can make money that can
solve problems that's competent that's
interesting um and they don't generally
do that again you know they're mostly
beta factories that that pump out these
soft versions of men that they kind of
wish that they were with in a long-term
basis to look after I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out